anyone who's lost something knows the
frustration of trying to find it
but most likely that pales compared to
what a man in newport wales lost and
where he's trying to find it mts taeb
reports
it's the seaside city in wales famous
for its docks
industrial heritage
and for allegedly having half a billion
dollars worth of bitcoin buried in its
local landfill
yes you heard that right half a billion
dollars in bitcoin is buried right here
in newport i've basically tried to put a
plan together to try and retrieve
you know the object and recover the data
former i.t worker james howell mined the
cryptocurrency back in 2013 well before
its value skyrocketed and in a mix-up
accidentally threw away the hard drive
its access key was stored on i found a
blank 20 gigabyte hard drive in my
drawer instead of thousands of bitcoin
since then he's been lobbying the local
government to allow him to excavate tons
of trash in the landfill as part of an
attempt to find it but local officials
are refusing
there are companies out there that dig
at the bottom of the ocean for treasure
digging a landfill is a damn sight bit
easier than digging at the bottom of the
ocean
howell says he's contacted experts from
around the world as part of his attempt
to recover his huge bitcoin fortune
despite offering newport city council a
cut of the coins if he were to find them
it continues to refuse the proposal
saying
one the excavation would be
environmentally damaging
and two that the council's duty is to
provide services to the public
something howell's plans would get in
the way of
still he's determined to keep trying i'm
not going to give up on it because it's
you know like i said it's a lost lottery
ticket
a lottery ticket would disintegrate but
a hard drive doesn't it's not going
anywhere a crypto needle in a haystack
that remains tantalizingly out of reach
to its rightful owner for cbs morning
saturday in pios pieztayab
london